first up he is the US Representative for
California's 28th district and the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee you know him you love a madam
chef
[Applause]
well a lot of people get standing over
time uh say you deserve that standing O
for you're not okay speech thank and you
delivered it great I gotta ask
maybe it's impolite was that it had lib
that whole speech or did you have that
ready to go well I knew the points I
wanted to make but I didn't write it out
because really I wasn't sure what they
had in mind but look at you know this
has been reaffirmed now by Giuliani and
the rest of the crowd they think it's
perfectly fine to take help from a
hostile foreign power to welcome it to
build it into their communications plan
they don't view that as collusion they
view that as just smart Rowlett --ax I
think it's unpatriotic I think it's I
think it's scummy yeah I think but I
mean the mullah report is at the end of
the day you know that firecracker that
yo goes up and then the one that fizzles
you know oh oh nothing
do you think you guys relied too much on
that look I was always of the opinion
number one that the Office of Legal
Counsel opinion that you can't indict a
sitting president was wrong oh good that
in fact you can indict a sitting
president you I think their Prudential
reasons not to try someone who's the
president states but particularly when
there's any risk of the statute of
limitations running if the president
commits a crime they should be indicted
and you should stay prosecution so
but frankly I had no expectation that
that would be the course Muller would
take even if the evidence supported it
because he is fundamentally conservative
and I don't mean left/right conservative
but he was going to follow the
established policy he was not going to
make new ground so I didn't think it was
realistic to expect that he would indict
the president and those that did I think
were unrealistic in their expectations
but I do think he laid out what we
needed to see which is that the Russians
were engaged in a systemic effort to
interfere in our election that the Trump
campaign welcomed it embraced it built
it into their plan made full use of it
lied about it covered it up and then
obstructed the investigation into it
and if we had any doubt before about
this president's fitness for office
there is no doubt remaining he is unfit
from the presidency
but but this was our big gun now it just
looks like you're stalking him I think
in the eyes of the people who don't
follow it that closely which is most of
the country was here's the thing about
Bob Muller he's like the last person
made the last thing in America that left
and right agreed on left and right
basically agreed this is a guy of honor
this is an honest guy this is an honest
broker whatever he says goes Americans
are not into details don't read it to me
Bob just give me a thumbs-up and
thumbs-down
the fact that he was like hmm I don't if
you were if you couldn't impeach before
how you gonna peach after or should you
well were you on yeah
I'm not there yet on impeachment I may
get there he may get me there but here's
here's the the awful dilemma that we
face if we don't impeach him that sends
a message that this kind of conduct this
obstruction of justice is kind of
willing use of the help of a foreign
adversary all the lies and cover-up that
this is non impeachable at the same time
if we do impeach him and he is acquitted
as he would likely be acquitted then the
message is those are not impeachable
offenses at the end of the day bill
there's only one way to deal with this
problem whether we impeach them or not
and that is to vote his ass out of
office
I I do think that I also think there's
one thing that the country is united on
at least a majority of Americans even if
it's not Bob Muller or in the report and
was summed up by my 91 year old father
who said that if it walks like a duck
and it quacks like a duck he's probably
a crook I think people recognize whether
he could be indicted or not that his
conduct is unethical probably criminal
in terms of at least the obstruction of
justice and we have in our power even if
we don't have it legislatively because
the GOP in the Congress will do nothing
to stand up to this man there is no
patriotism left in Trump's GOP but we
have it within our power we have it
within our numbers to turn out and vote
him out of office and we showed we
showed the power of that in the midterms
and the bigger the repudiation of him at
the ballot box the more it says to
ourself
okay so as the only Democrat not running
for president well you talk about you
know no you wouldn't you would do well I
mean you jump a close to the head of the
pack but so what is your advice because
I've all week what I heard was basically
two ideas that especially after Joe
Biden said but he said yesterday now Joe
Biden's view is Trump is the issue the
other ones are like let's stop talking
about Trump we talked about him too much
we want to tell people what we're gonna
do for them the health care environment
those kind of of kind of issues for
example you I've seen you on TV a lot in
the last couple years I know everything
you know or let you tell us about the
Russian situation
I don't know clue what you think about
health care I've never heard it yeah I
don't know whether you're for Medicare
for all or the
prove Obamacare or or get a chicken I
don't know what I I don't know what
here's what I was telling my colleagues
and particularly wonderful candidates we
had running in the midterms don't talk
about Russia you are not going to
persuade people to vote Democratic
Republican based on Russia or what about
Trump I get asked about it because you
know our investigation with the last two
years was the only investigation into
what Russia did right and people asked
me about it but what I urged the
candidates and what I urge our nominees
to talk about is how are you going to
help American people put bread on the
table how are you going to help them
provide for a secure retirement in an
environment which people don't stay in
the same job their whole life in a job
with globalization and automation how do
people get health care how do they keep
health care when they go from job to job
how do we help young people Ford college
those are the things we need to be
talking about we are in the midst of two
revolutions right now either one of
which would be phenomenally disruptive
the two put together are just producing
this Cataclysm of xenophobic populism
around the world and it's the revolution
the global economy through globalization
and automation when millions are losing
their jobs through no fault of their own
and it's the revolution in communication
which is every bit as significant as the
invention of the printing press but it
happened overnight where lies travel
faster than truths where hate goes viral
and you put those two things together
and it is a combustible mix and
addressing those challenges talking
about how in this environment we're
going to put people to work we're going
to deal with this yawning gap between
rich and poor we're going to make sure
that whether you have one job in the
morning and you drive an uber at night
that you have health care at the end of
the day and a retirement at the end of
your career that's I think what we need
to be talking about and I'll tell you
who I'm behind in 2020 and I'm behind
them a heart and soul any living adult
2020 anyone who gets the nomination we
all need to get behind whether we were
forum or not for
and let you go but I see I see you going
on Fox News well I I had some good
encouragement from someone very clever
studies going on Fox News now all right
love it it's okay
[Applause]
you